right now I am furious last week the
Florida high school there was a terrible
act of gun violence and the left had the
gall to use it as an opportunity to talk
about gun violence we've seen this
before it's when our Second Amendment is
most under attack an incident like this
takes place the Lib says that they want
some common sense gun reform but we all
know they just want to break into my
bunker steal all my bang bang toys and
smelt them down into Obamacare but every
time these freedom haters rage against
the machine gun we throw the book at
them specifically this book the playbook
for evading gun control debates now
loyola posers we'll remember we last
dusted this thing off back in October
and it's full of classic tactics like
now is not the time to talk about guns
or solving one thing won't solve
everything or hey what's over there
works every time
according to the playbook this month's
discussion should be just about wrapped
up until the next totally unforeseeable
tragedy but something strange has
bubbled up in the state of Florida no
it's not Pensacola subterranean meth
Godzilla we'll get to that later
apparently some of the students in
parkland didn't do the assigned reading
young students and teachers now
survivors are demanding tougher gun laws
[Applause]
my community and I have stared down the
barrel of an ar-15 the way you have not
how dare you tell us we don't know what
we are talking about with any movement
there comes this amount of heating and
trolling and people telling you that
you're just a little kid we won't stop
until something changes funded by the
NRA telling us nothing could have ever
been done to prevent this we call B BS
what don't you dare drag Blake Shelton
into this
he is just a family man who likes to hit
a button and spit in a chair look kids I
know what this is like teen whisperer
bill o'reilly says this political
engagement is just because you're in an
emotional state and facing extreme peer
pressure and phil knows a thing or two
about peer pressure his peers pressured
him right out of a job so he knows that
these opinions you're feeling right now
aren't real you know what look let me
rap at you guys oh hey I get it your
teens know you're growing into a new
body a new voting body it's normal to go
through some changes maybe your opinions
on welfare sprouted up overnight or your
views on taxes have gotten a little
hairy but you should not experiment with
gun control it's dangerous don't let one
fling with activism ruin your whole
conservative future this is why the only
safe method of civic engagement is
abstinence all the cool kids are doing
it or not doing it so the next time you
want to get hot and heavy at a protest
or go down on a ballot at a local
election just say no distract yourself
from these urges with a cool meme or a
lip-sync app with your favorite Blake
Shelton jam after all you're just teens
this isn't you you're probably just
being manipulated by outside forces you
know I'll let former congressman Jack
Kingston explain Jack I want to start
with something that you tweeted you said
oh really
students are planning a nationwide rally
not left-wing gun control activists
using 17 year old kids in the wake of a
horrible tragedy hashtag soros hashtag
resistance hashtag anti feh hashtag
dancey you're serious you think these
kids aren't acting on their own volition
let's ask ourselves do we really think
that and I say this sincerely do we
really think seventeen year olds on
their own are gonna plan a nationwide
rally yes right we all agree with Jack
here
it's totally fishy seventeen-year-olds
planning and nationwide rally doesn't
make sense what does make sense it's 17
year olds being bankrolled by a cabal of
shadow organizations covering their bus
fare
hashtag Soros resistance and Tifa DNC
see someone has to be pulling the
strings deeds have never driven
political change in America except for
the civil rights movement Vietnam War
protests women suffrage and the American
Revolution but those kids were all
jacked up on puberty hormones and
Hamilton lyrics I pay attention gun
control heads Hamilton was all about not
throwing away his shot sure he died from
being shot but there had been a good guy
with a shot there Hamilton might still
be alive today
cop soldiers be aware these school
shooting survivors aren't playing by the
rules and they are one of the
fastest-growing demographics in America
since Columbine more than a hundred
fifty thousand students in a hundred and
seventy schools have experienced a
shooting on campus making them a
legitimate voting bloc Donald Trump only
won the presidency by 80,000 votes so
I'm all for conservatives like Jack
Kingston and Bill O'Reilly bravely
fighting these children from a distance
but someone needs to do the hard work
and confront these parkland students
directly it's not gonna be an easy talk
for this sucker that has to do that and
I'm just now remembering that I'm
talking to two of them right after this
commercial break I'll be fine I'm an
adult and they're just kids
[Music]